my husband and I moved to London so I
got to work on internet in international
museums and so I chose an international
theme one of the other things that
drives endangerment is trade black
market trade in animal products and
animals second only to guns by some
estimates that it's a real big money
generator and the more endangered
something gets the more valuable is
which drives the desire to get it and
sell it on the market it was great fun
to be able to work at cue and work with
traffic international I was kind of a
nobody but I just sort of wiggled my way
in like a brash American because I
really wanted to get the research done
one of the things that one of the
reasons that I built this painting about
black market trade is that I also wanted
to talk about great market trade
something we don't talk about as much
it's an uncovered trade so you know
matsutakes can be found in the North
Pacific Northwest an individual
matsutake sells now for about seventy
five dollars in Tokyo that's a big
market driver and this thing on the
right of right is American ginseng does
not govern it is in mostly in the
Appalachians Great Smokies and the
Appalachians nothing wrong with it it's
a cash crop for poor Appalachian people
but it also happens to grow in an area
that has the highest endemism of
salamanders in the world and we don't
know whether it has an impact hopefully
somebody's written about it since I did
the painting that long ago kind of
growing out of this whole thing I
started working toward things that had
gone extinct so I began it took me about
I did about four years of research on
extinction because I had to kind of find
the pieces and follow the stories bit by
bit
what kept happening is oh it's safe well
this went to the brink and then was
found or it went to the brink and
somebody carefully brought it back the
Mauritius Kestrel up there at the top
was saved by one man over the course of
two years a whole species
oh sorry I lost my track each painting
begins as a database by the way not as a
drawing and I was already working on
building this gone database when this
sort of said but this is a great one you
know these things have come back so I've
read about this Magnolia in the secret
life of plants by Richard Attenborough
and BBC and it was about a Magnolia that
was found in Japan and a 2,000 year old
jar of rice some seeds were there they
planted them lo and behold it's a new
species and I thought well the how
perfect I'll use that it's kind of my
coat hanger you know how I arranged
painting and I'll find out about it
later so I just was busy working on the
painting and emailing people and all the
Magnolia people I spoke to who said
they're no their seeds are notoriously
short-lived I finally ended up writing
BBC ant and burrow the the
University of the Japanese researchers
couldn't find the researchers so I wrote
Gillian pranced who used to be the
secretary of cue and his response was is
he I can't help you with this one I
think it's a hoax the whole thing was a
hoax but I'd already done so much as it
worked
that I decide to leave it in there as to
represent our desire for nature to be
resilient
[Music]